le niveau de cette vanne que vous vous
allez gagner à la maison et bien les
deux petits chenapans du paf benjamin
castaldi c'est cyril hanouna ont passé
leur semaine à faire ça mais pas con
chroniqueur aux invités aussi mais même
parfois même à des gars très sérieux
regardez
[Musique]
en amour
philibert les barques le théâtre
une bonne nouvelle dans ce il est où là
mais où là où est-ce que vous avez revu
oui nico tête à tête au paddock
sous-canaux ma tête avec qui tu l'as vu
ou pas mon cul
oui
et quand même sous les 1 soit tu
sauveras de voir ce que voulaient les
revues montcuq pas d'excusés pas
d'excusés
[Musique]
et bon sang
je pense que c'est le tuer aucune forts
de l'histoire de papa est-ce qu'on peut
me l'isoler j'aimerais regardez bien
salée et l'alliance de castaldi derrière
et est à la tête de division je pense
que ce qu'on va voir si longtemps
celui-ci est énorme
c'est les boules au cul
[Rires]